hey guys um so in this series i'm gonna
start doing a bit of commentary
on um on videos that i've posted before
um this one i posted it was taken down a
little while ago
but i think the message is so powerful
it warns some kind of explanation
so let me uh let me play it for you here
five to succeed and to conquer the way
the all-time greats do
the all-time great have to have a chip
on this show yeah
if you don't have a chip on your
shoulder then you're not gonna be ever
reach the heights or take the measures
that it takes to become an
all-time great yeah me i had two chips
they rode me at the olympics
and i had a father that i separated from
that i know in my heart didn't really
want me
to succeed without him so those were my
chips
and because i had those chips i can't
lose
because if i lose he went you understand
me so in my prime if i lose
he went because he said i can't do
without him and in my life the way i was
talked when i was brought up
all i need is god nothing against my dad
but all i need is god
so my to me god prepared you to get me
to a certain level
where god took those roosters god took a
guy named charlie campbell
and you wouldn't know charlie campbell
because he was a boxer back in their
amateur boxing
but god showed me so much through
charlie campbell
that to this day i still speak to
charlie campbell
because without charlie campbell i might
have never gotten to be worried jonathan
really charlie campbell taught me so
much about
charisma that my father could never have
taught me
that it was unbelievable charlie
campbell beat all my father's fighters
as amateurs
that were in his weight class easily
almost every time
because he had charisma now they were
better than him
but he had charisma and he beat him with
that charisma how he beat him with
charisma because
he believed in himself he had confidence
and he knew how to
do stuff that made me love watching him
you understand me and he wasn't the best
puncher he really had the best boxing
skills
but his emotions he breathed everything
he did even though he was slapping
he had sharp breath with it yesterday
and
to me i was like whoa and he beating
these guys that almighty so they learn
the same thing i'm learning
but they can't have that kind of
charisma because my dad won't allow him
to beat him people
he won't allow them to perform with that
kind of confidence
you understand me so i need to learn how
to do what
he doing because if i can air what he
doing to what we doing
now i got something how did you
incorporate it well i started doing the
stuff he did
a little bit of it until i figured out
what it really was
you understand so some of the grunting
some of the morning he did while he was
fighting
to show that he had breath control i
started doing
so like when you hit bruce lee go whoa
try the camera would do stuff like that
in the boxing match
now his punches weren't nearly as
effective were nearly as effective as
the
sound was but he kept him on beat
and in tune with the sound so it made
him look way better than he really was
and he won the fights against these guys
because these guys don't know how to do
that
wow so i started copying some of it not
all of it but i started doing it added
to
my stuff when i met him it became hell
for all the little kids in the area
really what now i love charisma somebody
can't teach me and he beat my daddy
fighters
and to me these guys are older than me
i'm 12. they 17
he beating them so they ought to be
better at what we're doing than i am
because they're older and bigger than me
right he beating them
no i got to get that so i got it
so was it also like you obviously had
animosity with your father there was a
there was these so you were looking for
other ways to do it too
no i had to find other ways god had to
talk to me in other ways if god had
speak to me other ways
here's the real deal when people don't
understand there's nothing against my
father's just kind of our destiny right
when i'm lying this this is why i tell
people that nature is also a bible
right when a lion gets a certain age is
there to kick him out he got to go
you gotta go get your own pride because
this is my pride
and that's kind of how i met my father
so it's like
at a young age i knew i was gonna have
to go because just
the way things shaped up you understand
me so me growing up watching
even these guys watching before me i
watched all of them get to their age
but my daddy would never have a lot
would never allow them to be as
confident
and as charismatic as charlie campbell
was because
he didn't allow he's the boss he was in
control of everything but he ain't got
to fight nobody
right so then after the 76 olympics
god gave me a second confirmation howard
david jr won the vale barca cup
i mean he was the best fighter at the
olympics but he probably was the only
one gold medalist
that didn't become world champion why
because his dad had weighed him way too
long so he waited so long
that when he finally fought jim white he
couldn't beat jim what
because in howard davis the fire had
died
now his daddy the fight still was there
but guess what he didn't gotta fight you
what
right how it does right you understand
me
that was my second confirmation that
when i get old enough
i gotta go yeah you understand me so
it's like
i start to understand and like i said
nature has always been my bible
so people always say why you love
animals why you love chicken right
that's where i learned god's teachings
from because god made those animals
and people can't change you understand
me you can neuter them
but when you neuter them you change to a
whole another animal right and to me in
society
sometimes that's what they're trying to
do to us they're trying to neuter us yes
so when they neuter us we don't fight
pets
well that's a giant thing with men today
this one i'm trying to take it's with
toxic masculinity and all that [ __ ]
that's what i'm trying to tell you
they're trying to mentally neuter us yes
when they neuter when you neuter a horse
he becomes blind again he only don't
fight back no more
he don't care no more you understand me
so it's like if you knew that man
he becomes nothing he don't care no more
he ain't gonna fight me
he ain't gonna stand up for himself
cause he ain't got no
what god gave you took that out you fear
me and to me that's
emotionally mentally what they try to do
to us without physically doing it so
that was a problem that me and my father
also had and people said well why you so
against what goes on well to me that's
what he was trying to do
but what i learned is and it's going to
take you down that road too
i used to hunt when i was a kid right we
would hunt squirrels
when hunt squirrel there would be some
squirrels that would have a penis but no
balls
because the other scrub bit the balls
off the dead the daddy did it the daddy
have a nest
about anywhere from 10 to 25 females
every time one of them have a little
babies
he goes and bites nuts at all the meals
because he wants no competition i don't
listen but you got to know but you got
to know this
i get it so this shows me he can't do it
physically but this is what he's doing i
watch him do it to all these other guys
i told you about
before me they can't beat charlie
campbell because they're getting uh
the cameras are stuck yeah
he ain't better than them he ain't
stronger than him a better puncher than
them
but in in his mind he's a stud
in their minds they're getting because
my dad has made them
so he's mentally beat them down so low
that they have no real fight back in
them
because they got to be second to my
father first
i can't be that guy
so just just some commentary on this
you know he says nature is a bible
that's a very interesting phrase nature
is a bible
because when we think of bible we think
of a holy book
we think of something that's written
down you know something that cannot be
violated it's like a bunch of text
and this is the sacred text and you
shall not see anything
nothing outside the sacred text matters
you know for a lot of um
a lot of christians it's like that it's
it's what's written in the bible matters
anything outside the bible
not so much everything external must be
referred to back to the text
okay but here roy jones is saying
nature is the bible which means that
like
you know bible in terms of a a guide for
moral action a guide for living
a guide for what's right and wrong a
guide for
you know just a guide in general a guide
to live your life that's what a bible is
sorry because we
try to you know christians live their
life trying to
emulate jesus through the bible and roy
jones is saying that nature itself
is a bible you know so it's very
interesting basically he's saying that
god the divine order is communicated
to human beings not just through a book
or things that are written but it's
around us every single day
seen in all things nature is a bible
everything is nature you know
if what roy jones had a revelation
about the nature of the relationship
between him and his father and the other
fighters
and what he needed to succeed through
drawing an analogy
with you know what he learned as a kid
his insight into the father and the
squirrels and him biting the knights
nuts off all his male kids you know so
that pointed the way for him you know so
it's kind of a
it's kind of a lesson for all of us that
uh
the the wisdom we need to apply to
situations to solve problems to
apply to our personal lives whatever our
personal lives are
you could find analogy in nature you
know this is kind of what the the
e-ching is about
if you ever read the e-chain which is
the chinese ancient book of changes it's
a
one of the four great chinese classics
it's a divination book
well it's actually a book about it's a
book of just
insights about life and stuff like that
like it's you don't really believe in
anything
the belief more comes in if you uh toss
the coins do they really
say something about your question or not
that that aside
the book itself is a book of nature
analogies taoism is mostly about nature
analogies
and i think that's exactly the kind of
thing roy jones is talking about
looking at nature and seeing parallels
in
the things that you're facing and the
things that that you know you see around
nature
which unites you you with nature because
you're not separate from it at all
you are nature the promise you're facing
is nature you know
so nature is a bible you look to nature
to apply to your life
but if you do it well like your life can
be like a bible as well just like people
who
think that if they uh you know live like
jesus did
they are fulfilling the biblical uh
tradition and you know they will get
like a god's reward
if what roy jones is saying is true it's
like if you
live your life according to your your
what you see in nature
it's pretty much the same